to see people treat it like they did
horses barely running them over people
being strapped it's outrageous I promise
you those people will pay our entire
nation saw horrifying images that do not
reflect Who We Are
we know that those images painfully
conjured up the worst elements of our
nation's ongoing battle against systemic
racism so that was a year and a half ago
turns out that wasn't true and there's
been no apology since President Biden
Homeland Security secretary falsely
accusing border agents of whipping
migrants in the summer of 2021 now
emails are coming to light that show
that The Border Patrol's Chief was
Furious over how the White House handled
the bogus controversy Cross Country Host
Lawrence Jones is here hello to you sir
good morning I think one of these things
here that was going around at the time
is that the government is looking for a
clarification as the whether or not
we're going to investigate and the
sooner we can tell them that
investigation has been launched the
better it looks for them that's that's
what was going on on those emails but
meanwhile behind the scenes they were
also saying that there was no evidence
of wrongdoing at the time look you watch
Blue Bloods uh Frank Reagan I always say
when it comes to and y'all know I do a
lot of crime reporting so I have a lot
of sources in law enforcement
these positions are political
appointments and if you want to be a
successful commissioner Chief you got to
have the Frank Frank Reagan approach
that means you have the respect of the
rank and fi file while still being able
to maneuver in these political positions
and Ortiz behind deceased one of the
criticisms is behind the scenes he will
go to bat for his agents on the ground
but publicly he won't do anything to
support him and so he was in a tough
spot I I know Ortiz he's talked about
the problems that he's had with this
Administration but at the end of the day
majorcus is his boss Biden is is his
boss and he was going to do what they
said he was fighting for his agents
behind the scenes but I think what his
rank if I wanted to see this public
gesture saying you know what if you go
after my people you're going after me
and I'll walk off this job before I let
you prosecute for my uh agents on the
ground and he didn't do that publicly
let's read to some a little bit of the
emails that he sent so these are emails
that were just released this is call for
number one uh he said there are great
efforts occurring and we aren't
highlighting any of them every day we
are providing life-saving efforts to
migrants Under the Bridge our agents are
being assaulted and we aren't saying a
word the bus contractors and Pilots are
dealing with Haitians escaping or trying
to overrun drivers and we stay quiet
agents and Pro Staff are working 14-hour
days in difficult conditions nothing
said we have to change the narrative or
these stories will be the only story
well he's right yeah that has been let
me tell you something expect more
documents and and more comments to come
out of Ortiz office office I think he
realizes that he now has the political
will now with everyone talking about the
board of Biden finally visiting the
border the president is on his heels as
it relates to it and I think he's tired
of being beat up about this issue so I
think there will be more leaks about
what's really going on at the border
people should ask themselves where does
Fox News always get information from it
has to be with someone on with inside of
that Administration that is saying the
border is a crisis I think that's what
we're seeing right here yeah still no
apology meanwhile you won't get one uh
in Philadelphia you've been down there
you've been visiting a tough
neighborhood called Kensington there's a
new drug going around and this was
designed for animals and human beings
are taking it yeah xylazine also known
as train is a tranquilizer for Animals
we so we started covering the fentanyl
crisis about four years ago but now
they've introduced this new drug tranq
and the problem with this is that the
Narcan won't work on this drug and
they're trying all these different
combinations to try to have some
preventative measure but if you take
tranq it will kill you and if a EMT
doctor comes on the uh the scene they
won't be able to save your life because
of this it is but also it kills you
slowly it kills you very much the sores
that you can see that people get on
their arms and and their lit and their
legs it basically it you almost look
like you have leprosy because it starts
to eat you from the inside out what we
see is a lot of these offenders they'll
go go to jail and they'll be in jail for
like three months and then they'll
finally be released and they pick it
back up and that's when it really kills
them because they've went cold turkey
and then they get re-induced a lot of
the folks just to be clear don't know
that they're taking trains right they
have no dude it's been laced with it
strong stuff uh see you at 10 o'clock
Saturday night thank you so much thank
you for being here cross country good
luck to your cowboy good luck to your
Bangles thank you very much I know it's
on your mind I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis